[Music]
oh yes
she was you he has no one else
[Music]
[Music]
I cannot take her Maurice
[Music]
he has none of us apes together strength
[Music]
I see girl I think you human
but you hate like me put down how long
have you been here
[Music]
other more like you more apes from zoo
yet hold it long time human gets sick
eight get smart
Thank You Minh kill ape but not me I
thought you learn to speak listen human
bad ape no touch that that's mine new
friends special day you you keep
where did you get this bad place
humans ooh that human that humans
soldiers can you take us humans ooh no
no no go back there very safe here never
go back look look look
more snow can I go mistake
have you finally come to save your Avis
okay
[Music]
I'll get yours almost you
how did you know I was here I was told
you are coming more soldiers from the
north would be joining you here joining
good told you that
let's go okay here we go
or for the Planet of the Apes at its
heart is about the intimate relationship
between these characters what's so
exciting is that we are capturing the
actors performance tracking that into
these photo relays
you're him your sees it I fight only to
protect a you're just standing in for
the role until the magic son later on
you're not just representing the
character you are the character for real
Andy Serkis is an incredible actor he
has such an understanding of Caesar from
the inside hey let us go till your
colonel leave us the woods you will see
we are not savages when you're in the
audience what you're really looking for
is is that emotional connection that
can't be done by just somebody in a gray
suit that's just doing the body
movements that has to come from trained
talent okay what is a high-level visual
effects company they are the best
between what Andy did and what it did
the audience can become Caesar
emotionally Wetty is creating pure
artistry for us all of those details
that make the illusion complete whether
is push that further a typical shot will
start with capture being done on set
glad I can take this motion capture data
and make that translate into a character
that you actually can relate to the way
that you can read genuine emotion has
reached another level it looks insanely
realistic it's just such a brilliant
technology and I've embraced it and I
actively want to push the boundaries so
that this movie is the most thrilling on
every single level oops
together
oh yes child I don't know but she was
you
he has no one else we are not savages
apes fight only to survive bad human
kill eight all dead now a long time Oh
bad humans soldier
years from now your children will ask
you what did you do in the greatest war
and you can tell them I fought to
protect this world we created them but
now
[Music]
we will bring it in to their car
no mercy no peace this this war
rapes together straight you are
impressive smart as hell is stronger
than we are but you're taking this all
much too personally
so emotional
does not starve this war
but I will finish it
[Music]
I refuse to accept the end of man I
believe he will endure
he will prevail not because alone among
God's creatures he has a voice because
he has a soul spirit capable compassion
and endurance I refuse to accept the end
of man
he's a smart one this day what are you
gonna name him
does it look like just I'm Stan you
saved our lives
he was remarkable you're him you see
we've been searching for you for so long
I could not starve this I fight only to
protect things human get sick eaten get
smart that human guilt ate fanat me
there are times when it is necessary to
abandon our humanity to sing they must
pay how vicious I offered you peace I
showed you mercy
you talk about mercy no matter what you
say eventually you'd replace them that's
the law of nature so what would you have
done
what is the humans promise you
what you do shall never be one of them
are
have you come to save your a
[Music]